Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie.
Thank you everyone that submitted questions for this week's Game of Throne Q&A.
You know mostly questions about what's going on with Sansa and Ramsey.
But there were a couple really big ones that everyone had, so I'll just start with those.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
So starting with Littlefinger and Ramsey.
A lot of people were wondering whether or not
Littlefinger was lying when he said he didn't know anything about him.
Littlefinger is the master of lies
so I think he has an idea of what's going on with Ramsey.
I think he's heard things.
He might not know the whole story but he probably understands that he's very dangerous.
So I think that moment when he said I haven't heard anything about you was completely disingenuous.
He was just throwing a smoke screen at Ramsey.
And Ramsey himself was also lying through his teeth when he  said that he would take GREAT care of Sansa.
No surprise that everybody's lying.
So here we go, next question. SimsFinch asks:
So if Sansa and Ramsey are getting married there will have to be a wedding, right?
Yeah, I mean, it would be very mean to tease us with a wedding, and then not actually show it.
So I think there will be some sort of ceremon.
Because Tommen and Marjery's wedding seems
so normal I I think we can expect the
crazy wedding this season to be Sansa Ramsey.
There was actually a bunch of other
questions that like went to specific
details about this
so what is parsed through Sansa-Ramsey as
we go through the Q&A
it's gonna be a lot of fun this is
actually a new one the most interesting
storylines
despite being vastly different from the
books
next question choppy asks am I the only one that kinda
sees little finger as a snape type
character
not that little finger whatever redeem
himself. Wow. You don't sound very hopeful about Littlefinger.
it does seem like he has the best of
intentions with respect to Sansa
but he does have some some other grand
goal that she's only a part of.
I've also seen a lot of questions as to
whether or not little finger really
wants to sit on the Iron Throne
like it's clear that he wants to get rid
the Lannisters he wants to depose the
current rulers
but I think what he really wants is just
the power he doesn't want the actual throne
itself
like he if ends up being successful he won't
care who sits on the Iron Throne
is long as he's like the new Tywin
Lannister it kinda what's going on with
fares is character he wants to restore
another ruler to the throne he doesn't
necessarily wanna sit on it himself
all the other two I would say bears is
much more altruistic
other we really don't know the full
extent up what his intentions are
all we know is that he wants dinners on
a throne we don't know what he's going
to do after that
if he's successful I think a little
finger had his way he would prolly puts
and so on the throne
just because he knows the he has a
relationship with her shirley's listen
to him whether or not she actually trust
them
next question she a bigger jets why
can't the bones just
arrest little finger in San sample them
hostage enforce the north to obey
but the problem is is that a bruise
wants to keep the North
and if he wants them to like him like he
has to be able to work with them he
can't replace
all the people that live in the north if
he were to imprison or kill Santa
they would immediately turn on him the
only reassurance have controlled the had
before
came from Tywin Lannister town Minister
controlled all the money
all the troops now that he's gone roost
does not have a guarantee anymore
so he's the fight another source in
support that's the opportunity little
finger used to form an alliance with
them
next question and Caroline asks when
Ramsay was talking to little finger he
said
all never hurt her but we know he can be
a liar do you think that he will hurt
her
or maybe his partner in crime will hurt
her in some way so i think is going to
happen is is
Meranda will prolly take some shots at
her I'm I think they want you to think
that Ramsey is gonna do something
terrible the Sansa
this may be one of those situations
where the bike be in switch you
birds like brands is terrible clearly
he's going to turn Santa into his new
wreak
cut too shocking twist in in Game of
Thrones fashion as for with that which
could be it could be anything
when I really like to see is sent to cut
ramsey's sausage of luck on their
wedding night
exempt some crazy WTF moment like that
if certain events on the show seem like
they're building towards similar moments
that we've seen before
it on purpose like we're building
towards another
red wedding type moment we're building
towards another wreak type moment
so the twins would be is that you know
some torture is visited upon ramzi
himself
that's just speculation though as I feel
like that would be a fun way to close
ramsey's storyline
if he ended up losing his sausage next
question rubin asks
do you think that Aria will stop
training with the bases men because she
can't kills those she wants
it you can't look over past so I think
this is getting into like
no merit rant mace Tyrell territory
mantra is on her list and he is
escorting mace Tyrell to Bravos
so I'm hoping
is as they bump into each other he
doesn't recognize her but she recognizes
him
it tries to get revenge for what
happened a serial for L it's possible
that she could at that like choose
between
killing Mary Tran in doing something
else the jack and asked her to do
next question maria asks are you excited
or nervous to see how the show's change
sensor Jaime and Brienne storylines from
the books
yet I mean there's some really
interesting things that they could give
them
I think was gonna happen is is the log
raft storylines from other characters
onto their characters
a good example that is you know I'm
hoping they turn brie and into the ghost
of Winterfell
that story line from the bugs I spent a
lot on my videos you know leading up to
the season talking about dark Sansa
some hoping for medically she gets them
above the revenge story arc that they
gave two ladies don't hard
even though she's turning into more up
like a plotter schemer middle finger
type character
that an outright stabby character jamie
is still a bit of a question mark it we
haven't seen a lot of his character yet
some I'm gonna hold up on speculation
for him until we get down to dorn
next question dog lover asks what do you
think little fingers and game is now im
do you think the writers have changed it
since he is giving up the key to the
north to Reus
it seems to be forming an alliance
instead of going for chaos
well I think that his story line is
still very similar in that he's trying
to bring down the monarchy
it's really hard to tell where George RR
Martin is going in the book this is lose
the implied the little finger just wants
to bring everything crumbling down
because they are so many different plots
from so many different characters trying
to put someone else on the Iron Throne
when I'm hoping is the really be players
that survive all start to form
new alliances with the other big one so
this or do we know things down till like
too big teams little finger if he's not
successful in this plot to unite the
North
in the Vale him I just try to form an
alliance with dorn or with the nearest
I'll be interested to see though it did
they do decide to go the Gatsby route
with his character
birds like you know you get to the final
season you know book seven whenever
and he's like I did this all for you
Cattelan boy staring at Santa
just just completely out of his mind
next question though Norwalk asks
since joining kidnapped irian what is
more bears his role in the Targaryen
restoration
will you travel to marine yeah I meal
price to make his way there
what I'm hoping is is that he introduces
as to the group that's behind the
Targaryen restoration
as far as we know denarius and hurt her
inner circle
have their own plan to retake West rose
at some point and they're not
associated with the official Targaryen
restoration
that like a secret plot built by a group
of people that we haven't met yet
or maybe we have met them it you know
maybe that's part of what the Martel
storylines going to be
BS eventually I do think that various
will make his way to marine
next question pan asks what do you make
the look the red priest this in the
lantus gave the terry in
well actually I had a funny died you
know like hey I've read books 6&7 I know
what happens to you
in like she was laughing at him inside
quietly judging him just because she
knew how different things are going to
be from the show in the books
really though it which is the same type
have looked at Mill Sandra gives to Jon
Snow
she just sense is great destiny in him
the visions that the red priest can
conjure in the flames
can be interpreted a lot a lot a
different ways so she may not know
exactly who he is
only that he is a very important person
for what's to come
the war between the great other in the
forces the red gone because we're going
to see a lot more the East hopefully in
future seasons will actually get a
deeper dive
into the mythology of the red God it
would be pretty cool to see the inside
when the Red temples
if you didn't recognize right I said
something on Twitter but I'd I didn't
include it in my episode 3 video
that's actually really up to the Shema
from airship Lescott on on a row
she was also yukio in the Wolverine
stand-alone film
next question i've in US is price are
going to have a huge part
in the future story line 30 doesn't seem
to like him anymore I never read the
books but I have a feeling he's gonna be
a tracer seem
I I definitely think you're onto
something he made that comment were he
said
you know me and private life should
remain private as these other spares a
going around indicting everyone they
can't is that you know grabbing people
they think you're doing
immoral things getting rid the booze I
sell probably has like some
some pervy secrets he doesn't want to
get out that they will find out about
and he'll also be thrown to the Wolves
so what happened is like when everyone
starts getting accused the things they
start turning on each other
so I I definitely think that pay cell
will do something to try and save
himself
whether or not it's informing on search
the remains to be seen but remember
sir see when she was talking to Jamie
has been throwing caution to the wind
about the way she talks about their twin
says
in their children please if you have
read the bugs just used spoiler tags
because I do think they're going to be
doing
a lot of search the storyline from both
for don't be surprised if there are like
scenes from last season
that are mirrored in scenes this season
it just feels like a very TV type thing
for them to do wear it like
are the same things happening only now
it's happening to someone else
that goes for all the characters though
not to the characters in King's Landing
thank you everyone for so many questions
that is always a ton of fun to do dinner
I think we're really looking forward to
what happens between Santa and Ramsey
it's a big question mark because it's
not in the box but they could we have
some really fun stuff from which upon
the both so the bar in the heart home
storyline with many complaining that
would be like the most interesting place
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner lame duck in
UN HBO now subscription be sure to DM me
on the back into my chance I get your
contact info
and because the book giveaway winner
still haven't contacted me when I'm
gonna do is
is when we get the episode 5 the books
will just be part of that give away
so if you on the books you have two more
weeks to DMEM if you confused as to
whether not you want the books
it in my episode 1 cue in a video thank
you again everyone has been so many fans
as you guys have been a huge help
where you guys wait for next week's
burns me I'm still kinda up in the air
but as to what it's going to be probably
something martel related
you that King click here for my episode
3 video and you can click here to learn
all about the history of Winterfell
thank you so much watching everybody as
the guys tonight provides